WITHOUT. THERE'S NOT THERE BUT
THAT'S NOT ADEQUATE MEMBERS TO
DO REAL COSTS ARE GOING TO HOLD
OFF ON ROLL CALL. WE'RE GONNA
START ON MAKES AN ANNOUNCEMENTS
THIS IS THE FIRST TO A SESSION
OF THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR THIS TWENTY TWENTY
YEAR. SB FIVE THREE SIX US
SENATOR UMBERG'S HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA SB
SEVEN TO THREE- JONES IS ON THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR. SB
ONE SIX ONE IS BTES VOTE ONLY.
AND THAT LEAVES US FOR BILLS TO
DISCUSS AND AN AUTHOR HAS JUST
WALKED INTO THE ROOM SO WE WILL
START WITH SENATOR GALGIANI
COME MONDAY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADHERE TO
EXTENSIVE REPORTING
INVESTIGATIVE AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO MISSING PERSONS THAT
ARE ALREADY PRESCRIBED IN STATE
LAW. IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
THERE WERE TWO BILLS THAT WERE
PRESCRIBED TO CONFORM WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH REGARD
TO STAB WISHING MISSING PERSONS
DATABASES AND ALSO ESTABLISHING
A MANNER IN WHICH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD BE ABLE TO.
IDENTIFY PREVIOUSLY
UNIDENTIFIED MISSING PERSONS
THAT LAW WAS EXTENSIVE AND OVER
TIME IT CHANGED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN I AUTHORED SB TEN
SIXTY SIX AND SB EIGHT FORTY
SIX. TO AMONG OTHER THINGS
INCLUDE MISSED RISK DAHLE AND
THIS TO THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD
ONLY MANDATED REQUIREMENTS WITH
REGARD TO THE YOUNG PERSON. WE
HAD AN OVERSIGHT AT THAT TIME
WHERE THE ORIGINAL STATUTE IN
TWO THOUSAND OUT OF LOW THERE
IS A CHANCE TO EXEMPT
THEMSELVES FROM THE LAW AND
THAT WAS IN AND IT TO PROTECT
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT. WERE
UNDER FUNDED AT THE TIME TWENTY
YEARS HAVE SINCE PASSED AND WE
HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT IT'S LONG
OVERDUE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA REQUIRE
THE SAME STATUTE WITH REGARD TO
BOTH MISSING. YOUNG PERSON'S
OLDER. IN ADULTS THIS. TEMPLATE
UP DATE REQUIRE ALL TOWNIES
STATE FOLLOW THE SAME LAW I
RESPECTFULLY FOR RIVAL. THREE
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM JUST
CURIOUS. CENTER GALGIANI WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIX HAVE WE-
THE PROBLEM. YES WE HAVE
ACTUALLY I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE THAT IT THAT EXISTS IN.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAD LONG TERM
RECOVERY SAID FIVE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAD GONE MISSING FROM
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE AND
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND AT
THE DIRECTION OF. A SERIAL
KILLER- WHO WAS GIVING
INFORMATION DIRECTING TO WEAR
BODIES WERE BURIED THESE FIVE
INDIVIDUALS WERE RECOVERED
THERE WERE OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO CAME FORWARD AT THE TIME
WHO CLAIMED THAT THEY HAD HAD
MISSING- LOVED ONES WHO'D GONE
MISSING AND DURING THE TIME
THESE TWO INDIVIDUALS FOR
ACTIVE- SUCH EXAMPLE IS. A RED
JEEP MEANING WHO WENT MISSING
FROM CALAVERAS COUNTY AND WAS
APPELLEE FRIENDS AND CO WORKERS
WITH THE TO SEE TWO SUSPECTS
HIS WIFE CAME FORWARD ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION AND
INDICATED THAT SHE BELIEVE
HERSELF HER HEAD AND HER EX
HUSBAND WAS ONE ITEMS. HE WAS
NEVER EVEN WITH IT IS MISSING
HE IS JUST ONE. OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT I MISSED A LOT
OF- WE TRIED TO ADD INTO THE
DATABASE. SAID NEVER IDENTIFIED
TODAY AND IF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NEVER ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM
AND IF YOU NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE DNA TAKEN
AND SUBMITTED TO STATE NATIONAL
DATABASES THEN IF THERE IS EVER
RECOVERY THERE IS NO ABILITY TO
EVER IDENTIFY THAT INDIVIDUAL.
SO WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO GIVE
FAMILIES A BLIND THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE. AT
IDENTIFICATION IN THE EVENT OF
A RECOVERY. WILL NOT MAKE IT
RETROACTIVE IGHT TO KNOW IT NO
IT DOES NOT WE HAVE CONSIDERED
THAT AND WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT
THAT BUT THIS ONE DOES NOT. IN
SOME CASES IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO GO RETRACTED BUT WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT GOING
FORWARD ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPORTS EQUALLY. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY'RE OF WORLD COUNTY
OR AN URBAN COUNTY AND SECONDLY
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT IN THE
EVENT IN THE EVENT THAT A
FAMILY MEMBER COMES FORWARD.
YEARS LATER AFTER SOMEONE HAS
GONE MISSING THAT THERE IS THE
ABILITY TO REPORT AND ENSURE
THAT DNA IS SPEAKING IN THE
EVENT RECOVERY SO ARE ANY
COUNTIES- OR- POLICE
DEPARTMENTS NOT FILING REPORTS
CURRENTLY. AT THE ALREADY. UP
WE KNOW WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT IN
THE PAST THERE HAVE BEEN
COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT
REPORTED. ON THESE TWO
INDIVIDUALS WESLEY SHERMAN TIME
LEARN HERZOG WERE OPERATING
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. AND
SOUND LOOKING CALAVERAS COUNTY
IS THE BAY AREA IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WENT MISSING FROM CALAVERAS
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE
TIME THE FIFTEEN YEARS THAT
THEY WERE ACTIVE. THERE WAS ONE
INDIVIDUAL ROGER SHALL TOWN WHO
WENT MISSING DURING THAT TIME
THERE WERE MANY MORE. BUT
THAT'S BEFORE THESE BILLS. WERE
ENACTED SO WE'D BE FULLY SAID
AFTER THOSE INCIDENTS WE
SHOULD. REQUIRE REPORTING BUT-
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN OPT OUT
BUT NO JURISDICTIONS HAVE OPTED
OUT. IN OUR MANDATING THAT THEY
CAN OPT OUT I'M JUST. NO LOCAL
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVEN'T
ALWAYS FOLLOWED THE LINE AND
BECAUSE THEY HAVE OFTEN
THEMSELVES OUT I CAN'T LIST
EXACTLY WHICH ONES THERE ARE.
BUT IF YOU START LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE WORLD COUNTIES
AMADOR CALAVERAS YOU'LL SEE
THAT THAT. THEY THEY'RE ABSENT
MISSING PERSON RECORDS FROM
OLDER YEARS AND EVEN IF YOU
LOOK AND NOT ALL ARE REPORTING
EQUALLY THERE ARE COUNTIES WHO
REPORT THEM MISSING PERSONS ON
FACEBOOK SITES. FACEBOOK AN AYE
BIBLE CALAVERAS IS ONE OF THOSE
BUT THE EIGHT TWILA ME I
BELIEVE IS ANOTHER THAT REPORTS
THERE'S ON A FACEBOOK SITE
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD AS AN
ADDITION BUT IT DOESN'T DO ANY
GOOD IF A FAMILY MEMBER HAS
GONE MISSING FROM A COUNTY AND
THEY ARE NOT IN THE STATE WIDE
AND NATIONAL DATABASES AND
THEIR FAMILY HAS NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE DNA AND
THEIR BODY IS FOUND SOMEWHERE
ELSE. AND THEY'RE NEVER
IDENTIFIED. Q. I DON'T SEE
OPPOSITION BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWERING AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTION JUST TRYING TO I
KNOW THIS. WELL AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS ON
YOUR END THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU MANAGER CERTAINLY-
LET ME DO ROTH **** WE HAVE
QUORUM SELECT GET THAT DONE.
SKINNER I'M HERE MOORLACH
PRESENT BRADFORD ACCENT
MITCHELL. OUR WINNER. ALRIGHT
SO- AND I APPRECIATE THE LINE
OF QUESTIONING- SENDER MORE
LIKE BECAUSE THIS IS- BY MOVING
TO MANDATE YOU KNOW THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY COSTS AND THAT MAY.
YOU KNOW. THAT MAY IMPEDE THE
BILL LATER WE'LL SEE- THE ISSUE
OF MAKING SURE WE GET SUCH
INFORMATION AND DATA BASES. WAS
COMPELLING FOR ME SO HI BUT
BASICALLY- I REALIZE THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN HAVE- THERE'S
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO ADD HIM
TO ACT ON THE PARTICULAR-
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR GOLD YANNI'S PUTTING
BEFORE US BUT- I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT OF
COURSE MEMBERS WILL OBVIOUSLY
NEED TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS BUT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON. RIGHT WE HAVE MOTION.
ALL RIGHT LET'S DO A ROLL CALL
ON. SB THREE EIGHT EIGHT.
QUESTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MORLOCK. MORE LIKE
I BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL MITCHELL I AM AROUND
HI RALPH AYE WIENER. VERY WILL
HOLD THE ROLE AND THE- NO LET'S
SEE. US SENATOR ROW YOU ARE
GOING TO PRESENT FOR SENATOR
JONES IS THAT RIGHT NOT JONES
SKEWS ME BATES. CORRECT WAS
THAT CORRECT. OKAY YOU MAKE
AHEAD. AND THIS ONE IS SB SEVEN
TEN CORRECT ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
PROBABLY. LEFT MY TALKING
POINTS THERE. SLOW THIS MORNING
BUT I. WITH SIX. YEAH I DON'T
SEE HIM IN THE FILE MAYBE ON A
SECOND HERE. ALRIGHT OKAY I'M
READY I'LL I'LL GET IT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I.
IT IS EARLY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AT E. S. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GRACIOUSNESS BY AND I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL.
SB SEVEN TEN ON BEHALF SENATOR
BATES- WHICH ALLEVIATES THE
UNINTENDED IN- DANGEROUS
CONSEQUENCES OF RECENT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM BILLS. WITH THE
FOLLOWING FOR CHANGES FIRST IT
WOULD REINSTATE THE DNA
COLLECTION OF CERTAIN CRIMES
THAT WERE REDUCED. TO
MISDEMEANORS IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN PROP FORTY SEVEN RE
CLASSIFIED SEVERAL THESE FELONY
OFFENSES AS MR MEANER. I IN
ADDITION A PROP FORTY SEVEN UP
AND TOOK AWAY RIGHTS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COLLECT THE ANY
SAMPLES. FROM THOSE WHO
OFFENSES WERE ONCE CONSIDERED
FAMILIES AND SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN INDIAN A
DATABASE IS ALREADY EXPERIENCE
A DIP IN EFFECTIVENESS- SB
SEVEN TEN WILL RESTORE DNA
COLLECTION FOR CERTAIN CRIMES
IT REQUIRED DNA. COLLECTION
BEFORE THEIR RE CLASSIFICATION
AS MISDEMEANOR UNDER PROP FORTY
SOUTH. SEVEN SECOND SB TEN WILL
RE CLASSIFY SPECIFIC VIOLENT
CRIMES AS VIOLENT FAN- FELONIES
TO ENSURE INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED
OF THESE CRIMES ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE. OP
PROP FIFTY SEVEN'S PROPONENTS
PROMISE IT INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF A VIOLENT CRIMES
SUCH AS RAPE OF AN UNCONSCIOUS
PERSON IN IT BEING. OF THE
CHILD WOULD NOT BE RELEASED
FROM PRISON HOWEVER SEVERAL
COURT CASES APPROVING AT THESE-
VIOLENT OFFENDERS AGAINST
CHILDREN CAN BE RELEASED EARLY
IN TO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS MOST
RECENTLY A FELON CONVICTED OF
MURDER MOLESTATION OF AN ELEVEN
YEAR OLD. AND RAPE OF A
PREGNANT MINOR IS NOW AS A LOW
VALUABLE FOR EARLY RELEASE ON
THE PROP FIFTY SEVEN. SB SEVEN
TEN RE CLASSIFIES A VIOLENT
CRIMES WRONGFULLY CLASSIFIED AS
NON VIOLENT INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF SUCH VIOLENT
CRIMES WILL NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE
THIRD SB SEVEN TEN WILL EXPAND-
PROLIA OVERSIGHT IN STRENGTH
AND PENALTIES FOR PAROLE.
VIOLATIONS I DO THE CHANGES
MADE BY AB ONE ON NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN PAROLE.
DECISIONS ARE BASED SOLELY ON
AN INMATE'S COMMITMENT- OFFENSE
AND WILL NOT FACTOR IN PASS
OFFENSES THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT THE RESULT
IN CHANGING AB ONE ONLINE AS
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THE
MURDER OF WHAT YOUR POLICE
OFFICER KEITH BOYER- LAW
OFFICERS MURDER VIOLATED HIS
PAROLE. IN HAD BEEN FLASHING
CAR SERRATED SEVERAL TIMES
BEFORE SB TEN WILL REQUIRE THE
BORDER PEARL TO CONSIDER AN
INMATE'S ENTIRE CRIMINAL
HISTORY HISTORY INCLUDING ALL
CURRENT PAST CONVICTIONS.
LASTLY SB SEVEN TEN RESTORE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SEVERAL
THIEVES SERIAL THIEVES- PROP
FORTY SEVEN CHANGE THE
THRESHOLD FROM- FOR FIFTY FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS TO NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOURTH UP TO BE
CONSIDERED A FELONY. THIS MEANS
AS LONG AS INDIVIDUAL STILLS
LESS THAN NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS WORTH OF MERCHANDISE
THEY WILL ONLY BE CHARGED WITH
A MISDEMEANOR NO MATTER HOW
MANY TIMES THEY COMMIT THIS
OFFENSE. SINCE THIS CHANGE WITH
PROP FORTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA HAS
SEEN AN EXPLOSION OF REPEAT
PETTY THEFT OFFENDERS- AND AN
INABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES
EFFECTIVELY LAST YEAR HOME THE
PEOPLE WORK WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE YOU TALK TO
ADDRESS. SERIAL THAT IN AS A
RESULT ARSENE DECREASED AS- IN
STOLEN MERCHANDISE SB TEN SIX
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH
REPEAT PETTY OFFENDERS AND IN
A- FELONY PURSER OF THAT. THE
KEEPING CALIFORNIA SAFE ACT SB
SEVEN TEN WILL FIX THESE FOUR
MAIN PROBLEMS CREATED BY. LAWS
THAT HAVE- THREATEN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES FROM VIOLENT
CRIMINALS. THANK YOU FOR.
LISTENING IN YOUR TIME IN WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOW ARE SEEMS TO BE ONE. BY MEN
NOT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DON
CAP KEY ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THE-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU
MAY PROCEED. YEAR. STARTED
AGAIN. GOOD MORNING AND HAPPY
NEW YEAR MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- WITH GREAT RESPECT TO
THE AUTHOR AND TO THE CO
AUTHORS- CPA IS OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO REPEAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS PASSED
BY A MAJORITY OF THE VOTERS OF
THE STATE. ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE LISTED IN THIS BILL
WHICH CASTS A VERY VERY WIDE
NET- ARE INCONSISTENT WITH THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT THE INCREASED
PENALTIES DO NOT MAKE US SAFER.
ALL OF THIS WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
RACIAL MINORITIES. ALL OF THIS
WOULD MOVE US BACKWARD AND NOT
FORWARD TO MAKE US A SAFE AND
JUSTICE JUST SOCIETY. I
DISAGREE WITH THE DIP
INEFFECTIVENESS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN TERMS OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS THAT
HAVE PASSED- AND WE DO NOT-
HAVE STATISTICS THAT SHOW ANY
EXPLOSION. IN REPEAT PETTY
THEFT AS A PRACTITIONER FORTY
YEARS AN INDIGENT DEFENSE THE
PETTY THIEVES THAT I DEALT WITH
WERE. 95% PEOPLE WHO WERE- DRUG
AND ALCOHOL. AFFECTED IN MANY
MANY WAYS AND THAT'S WHO WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON AND NOT
FOCUSED ON PUTTING THEM IN
PRISON FOCUSED ON CHARGING THEM
WITH FELONIES AND- TAKING THEIR
DNA AND PUTTING THEM INTO
DATABASES THAT DO NOT HELP.
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBER HAPPY
NEW YEAR- MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN TEN I WOULD ECHO
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE- AND ALSO JUST ADD
THAT THESE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL HAVE BEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE- MULTIPLE TIMES IN
THIS COMMITTEE HAS REJECTED
THESE PROVISIONS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS REJECTED
VARIOUS ITERATIONS OF THIS
SPELL- IN BOTH HOUSES- AND SO
IT'S UNFORTUNATE TO SEE THIS
BROUGHT BACK AGAIN- AGAIN AT A
TIME WHERE CRIME RATES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE AT HISTORIC LOWS
THE VIOLENT CRIME RATE- IS AT
ITS THIRD LOWEST- IN RECORDED
HISTORY- AND AT A TIME MORE
CALIFORNIA IS RELEASED TRYING
TO SERVE AS A LEADER IN
PROTECTING VULNERABLE.
COMMUNITIES I THE BILL IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION AND MY
COLLEAGUE SAID- UNDERMINES THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS WHO
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED BOTH PROP
FORTY SEVEN AND PROP FIFTY
SEVEN- THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
THESE REFORMS I'M HAVE BEEN
UNSUCCESSFUL IN FACT THE
EVIDENCE- IS MUCH TO THE
CONTRARY- AND SO IS REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THE DIMARTINO THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE WE ARE
OPPOSED. I SPAWNING IS WITH CUT
FIFTY WE'RE OPPOSED. ONE FIFTY
WE ARE POST. KEN OLIVER WITH
ELLIS PC WE OPPOSE. RIGHT ANY
REMAINING RIGHT SO BEFORE I
LOOK TO MY COLLEAGUE SO ME MAKE
A COMMENT. ON AT. YES WE HEAR
FROM THE SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
THIS REFRAIN THAT- OUR POLICIES
THAT EITHER ARE VOTERS HAVE
APPROVED OR THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROVED ARE MAKING
CALIFORNIANS LESS SAFE
MEANWHILE WE HAVE. GOOD GOOD
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT CRIME HAS
CONTINUOUSLY SPECIALLY VIOLENT
CRIME PRIMARILY VIOLENT CRIME
HAS BEEN IN A DOWNWARD TRENDING
GOING DOWN EACH YEAR FOR THE
PAST AT LEAST TEN YEARS. NOW
SAYING REPEATING AGAIN AND
AGAIN THE UNICORN ISRAEL DOES
NOT MAKE UNICORN REAL THIRTY
EATING AGAIN AND AGAIN THAT
CRIME IS- VIOLENT CRIME IS UP
IN CALIFORNIA OR THAT POLICIES
THAT ARE VOTERS HAVE SUPPORTED.
IS CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR- TO A
TO A TO A HORRIBLE CRISIS OF
SAFETY IS DOES NOT MAKE IT REAL
AND- WHAT I. WHAT I RESPECT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA VOTERS IS THEY
SO FAR HAVE NOT FALLEN FOR THE
UNICORN ARGUMENT AND I HOPE
THAT THEY CONTINUE NOT TO FALL
FOR THE UNICORN ARGUMENT. ON I
WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THAT
THIS BILL I'M DOES PROVISIONS
OF BOTH PROP FORTY SEVEN AM
PROP FIFTY SEVEN. AND THEN THE
OTHER ASPECT ON THE DNA WELL I
AM A VERY STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
OUR USE OF DNA IN OUR
COLLECTION OF DNA. IN A SET OF
CRIMES BECAUSE OF ITS VERY
IMPORTANT EFFICACY IN TERMS OF
OUR- FINDING THE PERPETRATOR-
IDENTIFYING AND SECURING.
APPROPRIATE CHARGES ON THE
PERPETRATOR WE ALSO KNOW NOW
THAT LIKE ANY OF OUR
TECHNOLOGIES THERE ARE DOWN
SIDES TO THAT DNA ON. TO THAT
NEED FOR EXAMPLE. WE ARE NOW
HAVE EVIDENCE THAT A PERSON
THAT RECEIVED A BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANT. CAN. CHAU DNA OF
THE PERSON THAT THEY RECEIVE
THE BONE MARROW TRANSPORT
TRANSPLANT FROM SO THEY COULD
THAT COULD THEN PUT HEM AT
RISK OF COURSE OF BEING
CONSIDERED A SUSPECT IN A CRIME
FOR WHICH THEY HAD NOTHING TO
DO IT NOW WE WOULD HOPE THAT
ALL OF OUR OTHER INVESTIGATORY
TOOLS WOULD PROTECT SUCH
INDIVIDUALS BUT AS WE KNOW IT
IS NOT INFREQUENT FOR PEOPLE TO
BE WRONGFULLY CHARGED IN
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED SO I THINK
TO MOVE TO THE COLLECTION OF
DNA FOR MISDEMEANORS WHEN
THERE'S A LITTLE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE- COMMITTING OF SUCH
MISDEMEANORS AND THEN THE
POSSIBILITY OF COMMITTING
VIOLENT FELONIES. THIS DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE AT THIS POINT SO I
WILL BE VOTING NO ON THIS BILL-
BUT WELCOME ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
CENTER LARA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MAYBE AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
I DON'T KNOW BUT TO UNICORN
ARGUMENT BUT- I CERTAINLY HAVE
FRIENDS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING MY COUNTY SHERIFF
IT'S REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT AB
ONE ON NINE PROP 47-57 IN THE
IMPACTS ON ON THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE- SO- I DIDN'T COME
PREPARED FOR A BIG DEBATE BUT-
CERTAINLY. AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AT THE TIME
CERTAINLY SAW. A LOT OF THINGS
FIRST HAND SO I WOULD-
APPRECIATE THAT IF I COULD MOVE
THE BILL FOR ABOUT. RIGHT THE
BILL HAS A MOTION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES. YES GO AHEAD
SENATOR WIENER. DO. WE ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE THE- FACT OF. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON ALL
THE AUTHORITY- NO TODAY ON THIS
MEASURE- ID- YOU KNOW I AND I
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW I ALSO IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE A PERCEPTION SAN
FRANCISCO- IS ALWAYS A CERTAIN
WAY BUT YOU KNOW I THINK PEOPLE
WANT TO FEEL SAFE- EVERYWHERE-
AND- SOMETIMES- PEOPLE. I THINK
THAT SOME OF THESE LAWS ARE
SOMEHOW UNDERMINE INNER CITY
AND I AND I ACTUALLY DON'T
THINK. THAT THAT IS TRUE AND IN
PARTICULAR I ONE THING I AND I
CURE LAW ENFORCEMENT SAY THAT
SOMETIMES THAT OKAY THIS. BIRD
IT. TO ME. AND SO- WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE- LAST I
CHECKED IF SOMETHING IS A
MISDEMEANOR YOU CAN BE ARRESTED
FOR THAT YOU CAN BE PROSECUTED
AND YOU CAN SPEND SIX OR TWELVE
MONTHS IN COUNTY JAIL ON IT SO
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS A
MISDEMEANOR. DOESN'T MEAN YOU
CAN'T BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
BUT HOLDING SOMEONE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR DOESN'T MEAN
YOU HAVE TO DESTROY THEIR LIVES
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLODE POPULATION
OVER STATE PRISON SYSTEM. TO
THE POINT WHERE YOU SEE AN CSU
STUDENTS ARE HAVING TO PAY
TUITION THAT THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD- WERE IF USER YOU KNOW
CHOICES THAT WE MADE- THEY
HAVEN'T BUT DID NOT MOVE WENT
THROUGH ALL THE DECADES OF
ADDING SO MANY NEW STATE
PRISONS EXPLODED OUR STATE
PRISON POPULATION THAT DID NOT
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER- BUT IT
IT UNDERMINE THINGS LIKE THE
CASE PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION-
SO ID- YOU KNOW I WE MUST HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
BEHAVIOR BUT WE CAN DO IT IN A
WAY. THAT DOESN'T EXPLODE THE
PRISM BUDGET- AND DOESN'T TEAR
COMMUNITIES APART I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MANAGER. COUPLE THINGS. EIGHT
THE BONE MARROW COMMENT THAT'S
MAYBE ONE IN A MILLION IT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN MUCH BUT STILL GET
COULD HAPPEN I HAVE THREE BUT-
WOW. AND THE STATISTICS OF
CRIME GOING DOWN ME ONE OF THE
REASONS I'VE BEEN TOLD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASK BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ARREST PEOPLE. I'M SORRY IN. MY
SPEAKING TO YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU- IN AND LASTLY ON ON JUST I
SPEAK TO A LOT ALONG FORSMAN
PEOPLE AND THEY DO TELL ME-
COUNTY RIVERSIDE THIS WAS WELL
SAM DO YOU KNOW. ORANGE COUNTY
THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
ARREST THESE FOLKS- THESE DAYS.
IN AND ANOTHER THING TOO I KIND
OF. WASN'T SURE WHAT. SENATOR
FROM SAM CISCO SAND BUT- A IN
HERE BUT I HOPE YOU DIDN'T SAY
SAM SAYS WAS A SAFE PLACE
BECAUSE EVERYTHING YOU READ THE
NEWS. OAKLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO
AND LOS ANGELES- ARE
EXPERIENCING. SOME REAL
CHALLENGES IN AND- THERE'S A
LIST OF REASONS WHY PEOPLE
LEAVE CALIFORNIA'S YOU KNOW
ALL. OVER MILLION HAVE LEFT IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS PART OF ITS
HIGH TAXES- BUT ALSO CRIME. AND
FILL IN UNSAFE SO ANYWAY EY
LOOK AT THAT'S THAT'S MY-
CLOTHES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH.
AND THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
PATIENCE WITH ME EARLIER THANK
YOU. NOT A PROBLEM. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL. WITHOUT IT THE
COMMENTS WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL ON. SB SEVEN TEN. MOTION
IS THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER NO SKINNER NOW MORE
LOCK WELL LIKE I BRADFORD
BRADFORD NOW JACKSON JACKSON
NOW MITCHELL MORALE I HAVE A
REAL AYE WIENER WIENER HIGH.
WHEN YOU ARE YOU KNOW WE ARE
NOW. RIGHT THANK YOU A CAMERA
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
THE WE HAVE ANOTHER OFFERING
THE ROOM. THEN WE WILL HAVE
SENATOR BRADFORD. THAT'S IT
OKAY. RIGHT YES. EMPLOYERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WILL
START WITH. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
PRESENTATION OF THE BILL AS SHE
ARE SIXTY AND OUR DIGNITY
INCARCERATED WORKERS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AS C. E. R. SIXTY
NINE EXPRESSES LEGISLTORS
PORT. FOR FAIR AND JUST WAGES
FOR INCARCERATED PERSONS AND
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO EXAMINE
THEIR PAY SCALE AND EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOR THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
ABOLISHED SLAVERY EXCEPT FOR
THE PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME. THIS
PROVISION IT- THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT OPEN THE DOOR FOR
PRISON LABOR AFTER THE CIVIL
WAR AND CONTINUE TO. THE EARLY
NINETEEN FORTIES INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WERE LEASED OUT TO
PLANTATION OWNERS ARE
MANUFACTURED FOR CHEAP LABOR
THE SYSTEM WAS LATER REPLACED
WOULD WHAT IS COMMONLY KNOWN AS
THE CHAIN GANG WERE SHACKLED
INDIVIDUALS WERE FORCED TO
WORK. HELPING BUILD OUR OUR
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS
BRIDGES AND HIGHWAYS. THE HUMAN
A HUMAN IS A- AS IN OUR STATE
PROP WAS WIDESPREAD THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA OR OR FORTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE IMPRISONMENT
WORK FULL TIME EARNING
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN EIGHT CENTS
TO THREE DOLLARS AND NINETY
CENTS TODAY A DAY. OF THE FORTY
TWO THOUSAND CARS WORKERS OVER
THREE THOUSAND CARS OR IF
PEOPLE WORK FOR MERGE THE
FIREFIGHTERS RISKING THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR SAFETY AND
PROTECTION OF OUR- TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES. ANY EARN ON
AVERAGE OF A DOLLAR AN HOUR.
NOT ONLY ARE THE EMERGENCY FOR
OUR FIGHTERS PAID ONE TWENTY
SEVENTH OF THE EARNINGS FOR
SWORN FIREFIGHTERS. THERE ARE
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE OBJECTED RELATED.
OBJECT RELATED INJURIES AND
EIGHT TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE SMOKE INHALATION
RELATED TO- THE WORK WITH IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM THOUSANDS OF
INCARCERATED LABORS WORK
ABSOLUTE TRADITIONS CARPENTERS
COOKS ORDERLIES BRAILLE
TRANSCRIBERS SOAK SCREENERS AND
MANY OTHER AND TRICKLED
POSITIONS ESSENTIAL. ODD TO THE
OPERATIONS OF OUR STATE. IT'S
ANOTHER SEVEN THOUSAND
INCARCERATED WORKERS ARE UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON INDUSTRY AT
THE WILL BE CAPITA ALL WHICH
MANUFACTURES AND SELL PRODUCTS
MADE BY INCARCERATED WORKERS
CAL PJ. NEVER AGAIN REVENUE
BECAUSE THE STATE POLICE MARKET
RATE FOR THESE ITEMS IN THE
WORKERS ASSEMBLE AND
MANUFACTURE THESE PRODUCTS EARN
ONLY A FRACTION OF THE MARKET
WAGE INCARCERATED. WORKERS
PRODUCED OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
GOODS AND SERVICES INCLUDING
WORLD FINDS CLOTHING CLEAN BOX
LICENSE PLATES AND OFFICE
FURNITURE ABA WHICH IRONICALLY
MUCH IS IN THE SPRING TODAY.
AIMED INCARCERATED WORKERS A
FAIR AND JUST WAY TO WILL NOT
ONLY PER INDIVIDUAL INCOME
COMMUNAL ECONOMIC STABILITY BUT
IT ALSO FROM PROVES PERSONAL
DIGNITY THE ABILITY TO SAVE AN
ACCUMULATE- WHILE IN PRISON
AFFORDS INDIVIDUALS AT ADEQUATE
YEAR OF THE WORK THEY ARE
PERFORMING AND BETTER PREPARES
DOWN. FOR THE COMMUNITY WHICH
THEY WILL RETURN TO. ESTIMATES
INDICATE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ALL 60% OF THEIR INCOME
TWO FORMS OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DEBT. AND ONLY 55% OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
REPORTED EARNINGS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR AFTER BEING RELEASED
WHICH INCREAES WITH INCREASED
WAGES INCARCERATED WORKERS CAN
CONTRIBUTE MONETARY MEANS. TO
THEIR FAMILIES PAY CHILD
SUPPORT DRASTICALLY DECREASED
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY OWE
TO RESTITUTION AND ALLOWS. FOR
THE ACCUMULATION OF SAVINGS TO
A SYSTEM ONCE THEY MAKE THE
TRANSITION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY MOST IMPORTANTLY
INCREASE WAGES WILL HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RECIDIVISM. AND MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER WITH ME
TODAY IS KEVIN OLIVER FROM
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND YES- BUT
DARLE BUT OUR LOW OF THE
WESTERN CENTER OF LAW AND
POVERTY AND I REQUEST REVIVAL.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JESSICA
BARTOLO THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AS YOU KNOW THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WORKED ON BEHALF OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE IN THE COURTS. IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND BUDGET
ADVOCACY. WE ARE REALLY PROUD
TO COSPONSOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BECAUSE- OF. THAT
SO MANY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
IMPRISONED IN CALIFORNIA ARE
POOR. THEY WERE POOR BEFORE
THEY WERE STOPPED THEY WERE
SUPPORT BEFORE THEY WERE CITED.
BEFORE THEY WERE ARRESTED.
BEFORE THEY WERE. CONVICTED AND
BEFORE THEY WERE DETAINED IN
PRISON. NOT ONLY THAT 54% OF
THEM ARE PARENTS THEY LEAVE
BEHIND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AT
HOME THEIR FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING WITH POVERTY WITH
THE BENEFIT OF ONE INCOME AND
NOT TO AND THAT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WORKING FORTY SIX
THOUSAND. PEOPLE IN PRISON
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA ARE WORKING
THEY HAVE A JOB BUT AS YOU
HEARD THE SENATOR TESTIFYTHE
EARNINGS AND HE'S ON THE
DOLLAR. WHEN THEY DO RECEIVE
AGE 55% OF THE IN PRISON GOES
TOWARDS RESTITUTION AND IS PAID
TOWARDS THE VICTIM SO NOT ONLY
ARE FAMILIES LOSING OUT BACK
HOME BUT SO ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE. COUNTING ON THE
RESTITUTION TO MOVE ON WITH
THEIR LIVES. SO WHERE DOES THAT
FAMILIES. RECEIVE OF ART THAT
PEOPLE RECEIVE IN PRISON AS USE
AS YOU HEARD- CAN RANGE
BETWEEN. EIGHT CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR EIGHT CENTS PER HOUR TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE DOLLARS AN
HOUR. AND AGAIN ADD THESE TO
OURS- GO TOWARDS RESTITUTION
THE OTHER THINGS THEY DON'T GO
TOWARDS OUR CHILD SUPPORT-
PEOPLE IN PRISON YOU STILL NEED
TO PAY FOR A PHONE CALLS PHONE
CALLS HOME. PHONE CALLS TO
PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
RETAIN THOSE CONNECTIONS AND BE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN RE
RECIDIVISM ARE TO PREVENT
RECIDIVISM WHEN THEY RE ENTER
AND ALSO TO PAY FOR PERSONAL
HYGIENE MANY PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. PERSONAL
HYGIENE IS NOT COVERED- AND
MANY ITEMS OF PERSONAL HYGIENE
IS NOT COVERED WHILE IN PRISON.
AS WE MENTIONED BEFORE AT AN
AVERAGE OF. ABOUT 40% OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED HAVE
CHILDREN. THIS MEANS ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY- CHILDREN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE A
PARENT IN PRISON. IN
CALIFORNIA- WE CAN EXPECT THAT
THE SAME PERCENTAGE IS ABOUT
THE SAME AND THAT ABOUT 11% ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHILDREN. AND
ABOUT THREE PERF AT 5% OF AT
HISPANIC OR LATINO CHILDREN
HAVE A PARENT IN PRISON THIS
COMPARED TO ONLY ABOUT 2% OF.
OF WHITE CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED PARENTS. SOME
CLOSING. WE WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT SEARCHED FOR CHANGING A
PRISON WORKERS BECAUSE IT SAVES
THE STATE MONEY IS PENNY WISE
POUND FOOLISH IT UNDERMINES
RECIDIVISM IT INCREASES POVERTY
AT HOME IT LEAVES VICTIMS
WITHOUT RESTITUTION PAYMENTS
THEY SHOULD GET AND IT MAKES IT
REALLY HARD FOR. TO REENTER
COMMUNITY INCREASING PRISON
COSTS LATER DOWN THE ROAD. AND
MORE THAN THAT. IT MAKES PEOPLE
SUFFER FROM AS YOU WILL HEAR ME
TESTIFY THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WHEN A CHILD IS IN POVERTY. I
THEY'RE GOING WITH OTHER BASIC
NEEDS. AROUND WITHOUT FOOD FOR
GOING WITHOUT SHELTER. THEY'RE
GOING OUT WITHOUT HUMAN DIGNITY
THAT THEY NEED TO GROW HEALTHY
AND OUR GREAT STATE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT WHAT.
MEMBERSHIP PERSON WITH THE
AMOUNT OF THINKING ABOUT IT
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME OF- BUT
A MERE GLIMPSE OF- BY MY
COLLEAGUE TO THE RIGHT SO
ELOQUENT SPOKE ABOUT- I DID
TWENTY FOUR YEARS IN PRISON
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S THREE
STRIKES LAW. FOR NON VIOLENT
CRIME- UPON MY RELEASE ABOUT
SEVEN MONTHS AGO OUR DEPLOYED
BY LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN- AS A PARALEGAL
IN A COMMUNITY- ORGAN- WE'RE
HERE CO SPONSORING AND
SUPPORTING- SCR SIXTY NINE
BECAUSE IT RESTORES DIGNITY AND
OF FAIR WAGES TO PEOPLE IN
PRISON- THE- THE PROBLEM THAT
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH- DURING
MY TWENTY FOUR YEARS MAN COST
RATIO I WORKED APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY OF THOSE YEARS- BURN.
MORE THAN FIFTY TWENTY MONTH
AFTER RESTITUTION WAS A- OUT OF
A PAYCHECK. I LEFT THREE SMALL
CHILDREN BEHIND AT FOUR FIVE
YEARS OLD FOUR FIVE AND SIX
YEARS OLD- UPON MY REST- DURING
THE ENTIRE COURSE MY
CORPORATION I WAS NOT ABLE
FINANCIALLY TO HELP SUPPORT MY
CHILDREN I OFTEN HAD TO RELY
ON- EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS MY
PARENTS MY SISTERS- IN BROTHER
TO HELP OF PROVIDE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT MY CHILDREN- OFTENTIMES
I WAS AT. THE BOTTOM BIRTHDAY
GIFT SIR. IS MISS GIFS OR
SUPPORT THEM. DISTANCE IS OFTEN
AND REMOTE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
TO VISIT- WHICH ALSO PRESENTED
PROBLEMS FOR ME TO HAVE
CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION TWO
PHONE CALLS. SURE MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE OF GTL THAT IS OUR
MAIN PHONE FEES IT CAN
SOMETIMES ONE HUNDRED TO THREE
DOLLARS A MONTH JUST TO KEEP IN
CONTACT WITH FAMILY ON A
REGULAR BASIS- SO THE IDEA OF
WORKING IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT.
IN THIS IN THE IN ESSENCE IT IS
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE MADE A
VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR ME
FINANCIALLY- TO SUPPORT THOSE
THAT I LOVE AND IN ADDITION TO
PAY RESTITUTION TAKE YOUR MOM
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE WAY IT'S
SET UP IN CALIFORNIA THE ARE
NOW. IS THAT WHEN PEOPLE LARGE
AMOUNTS RESTITUTION IF THEY'RE
NOT WORKING OFTENTIMES ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THAT TO CARRY
THE BURDEN OF THE RESTITUTION
BASED ON THEM TRYING TO SUPPORT
YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
HYGIENE. MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE THE NECESSITIES TO SURVIVE
IN A PRISON ENVIRONMENT- WHICH
IS PROBLEMATIC THIS FROM A%
RESPONSIBILITY STANDPOINT IS
THAT YOU PASS THAT BURDEN ON TO
PEOPLE WE'VE ALREADY HARMED-
YOUR FAMILIES WITH OFTEN CAN'T
AFFORD EITHER SO WHEN THE WHEN
THE IDEA OF COULD YOU SEND ME
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO GO TO
CANTEEN TO GET SOME BASIC
NECESSITIES AND YOU ONLY GET
FORTY FIVE. OR THAT IT'S
PROBLEMATIC WITH THEM THEN I
WANT TO DO IT. OFTENTIMES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T. WANT TO.
FOR YOU. MOTHER EXPERIENCES IN
PRISON AND REFERENCE TO WORK-
WHEN I WASN'T WORKING I
ATTEMPTED TO GO TO COLLEGE
SEVERAL TIMES PRIOR TO- JUNIOR
COLLEGE BEING ACCESSIBLE TO
PRISONERS NOW IS IT IS- AND IT
WAS PROBLEMATIC FOR ME FROM A
FINANCIAL STANDPOINT TO PAY FOR
TUITION AND ABOUT MY OWN SCHOOL
BOOKS WHICH MOST OF THE COLLEGE
PROGRAMS REQUIRE YOU TO DO- FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU GO TO- AN
OUTSIDE THE STATE INSTITUTIONS
OFTEN SEVEN OR EIGHT HOURS OF
COURSE. OF THE BOOKS CAN BE A
HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A PIECE AND IF YOU HAVE
ANYBODY TO PAY FOR THOSE THINGS
IN YOUR ACTUAL ACTUALLY STOP
FROM BEING ABLE TO GO TO
COLLEGE FOR MYSELF IT WAS A
PROBLEM BECAUSE THAT ACT TO
GRADUATE HIGH RIDER TO RATIONS
SO BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT. AT
THE TOP CAME IN DIDN'T OFFER.
EDUCATE OUT TOMORROW VICES. IT
MADE A PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE I
WASN'T ABLE TO FOR- ADVANCE
AMOUNT EDUCATION SYSTEM. ARE OF
MY OWN EDUCATION- SO TO ME IT
IT'S A IT'S A VERY CHALLENGING
PROBLEM- AND ALICE PC BELIEVES
FIRMLY THAT- INSTITUTING FAIR
WAGES ACROSS THE BOARD AND
CALIFORNIA PRISONS WILL ALLOW
US TO. SUPPORT OURSELVES AND
SELF DETERMINE A LOUD TO BEGIN
THE WORK. WELL OUT OF THE HOUSE
SO THAT ARE IN PRISON WITH
PEOPLE ACTUALLY ABLE TO RUN
THEIR OWN. THE LEFT TO. THE
STILL BAGS SUGAR OUT OF THE
KITCHEN GOES. ON THE MAIN LINE
IN PRISON TO HUSTLE UP BARS OF
SOAP AND IN A BAG OF CHIPS FOR
SNACKS OR WHATEVER. UP ANOTHER
THING I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TODAY
SPECIFICALLY IS ABOUT RE ENTRY.
GET MONEY CALIFORNIA'S BEEN THE
SAME FOR FIFTY YEARS. TO OUR
DOLLARS AND IT HASN'T KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION WHICH I BELIEVE
NOW THE NUMBERS ARE EVER HEARD
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE REPRESENTS. A FIVE
HUNDRED TODAY WELL THE ONLY
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF
THE LOOP OR CALIFORNIA
PRISONERS AND- THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT IS THAT WHEN A PERSON. YES
RELEASE FROM PRISON TODAY AFTER
DOING TWENTY THIRTY YEARS. THE
GIVEN TWO HOURS GAVE MONEY IN
RECEIVING A RELEASE. PRIOR TO
LEAVING RECEIVING A RELEASE YOU
HAVE COMPANIES LIKE ACCESS INTO
T. O. WHO INSTITUTED THE DEBIT
CARD SYSTEMS WITH CDC ARE WITH
THE TAKEN FIVE DOLLARS PER
TRANSACTION. AND SO BY THE TIME
YOU LEAVE OUT OUR IN OUR WITH A
TEE SHIRT. KHAKIS AND A PAIR
OF- OF BENTON'S USUALLY LEFT
WITH SEVEN DOLLARS AND A BUS
TICKET. TO ARRIVE IN LOS
ONE OF
AREAS. INTO YOUR TWO WEEKS OUT
BASICALLY FROM SUPPORT SERVICES
A SOCIAL SERVICES THAT EXIST IN
THE CITY'S- BEING ABLE TO
ANSWER TO FAIR WAGES. WE WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY BUILD
MONEY IN SAVINGS VERY SIMILAR
WHAT. HE DOES WITH THE JOINT
VENTURE PROGRAM. IN CALIFORNIA
PRISONS WHERE THEY ALLOW
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO COME IN
AND PAY MINIMUM WAGE TO THE
WORKER- WHICH IS IRONIC BECAUSE
WE REQUIRE THAT BY LAW WITHIN
TI. DOESN'T HAVE TO DO THAT. SO
PEOPLE. ACTUALLY OF A BANK
ACCOUNT SAVE MONEY UPON THE
RELEASE OF WORK IN. PAROLE WITH
YOU KNOW TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT YOU SAVE
OVER THE COURSE OF. TIME ALLOWS
YOU GET PERSON LAST MONTH ON
HOUSING. IT ALLOWS YOU TO GET A
VEHICLE ALLOWS YOU GET CLOSE
ALLOWS YOU KIND OF GET ON YOUR
FEET IN SUPPORT YOURSELF. UP
WHICH IS IT WHICH IS NEEDED
BECAUSE WE SHOW PART FOR A
RECIDIVISM OCCURS WITHIN THE
FIRST NINETY. DAYS TO ONE YEAR-
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IF WE ALLOW
PEOPLE TO SELF DETERMINE EARNED
MONEY THAT ALLOW THEM EASIER
TRANSITION UPON. OF SOME PRETTY
ACTUALLY. INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY BECAUSE NOT PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE SUPPORT SYSTEMS
WON'T. BE FENDING FOR
THEMSELVES WITH ECONOMIC
STRESSORS- WITHIN THE FIRST
THREE TO SIX MONTHS GETTING OUT
AND THIS MAY CAUSE THEM TO. A
WEEK CRIME. THAT YOU KNOW WE
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU'RE- MISSION
AND APPLY FAIR WAGES IN THE
PRISON ENVIRONMENT TO ALLOW
PEOPLE SOME SENSE OF DIGNITY
AND TO ALLOW THEM A BETTER
CHANCE A TRANSITION WITH A
RELEASE. THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE MAYBE JUST
LESS THAN A MINUTE I'M A
CRISTINA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. A WE'RE PLEASED TO
BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. EVERY ONE DESERVES
DIGNITY IN THEIR WORK. UP
PAYING INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR DOESN'T
REFLECT THE COMMITMENT TO
REHABILITATION PAYING
RESTITUTION AND CHANGING A
PERSON'S VALUE OF WORK. OF
WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR AND
QUESTIONING THE JUSTICE OF
PUTTING INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND IDEALLY TO
ENVIRONMENT IMMEDIATE DANGER TO
THEIR LIFE AND HEALTH BUT ON
THE SUBJECT TO THIS RESOLUTION.
WE THINK CARE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
REFLECT ITS STATED COMMITMENTS
AND VALUE THE WORK BY THESE IN
CAR INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WE
ARE SUPPORT. THE OTHERS CAME
AND. GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS
FOR ONE FAIR WAGE AND FOR ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. K. BEHALF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA THE STRONG
SUPPORT. EVERYTHING IS A CUT
FIFTY INCARCERATIONS DOES NOT
JUSTIFY IN HUMANE COMPENSATION.
SHOULD JOSH PARRIS ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSORING STRONG
SUPPORT. OLIVIA CORNING CUT
FIFTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL WINDOWS WITH A FIFTY
STRONG SUPPORT. A SPONTANEOUS
WITH CUT FIFTY INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT. IN THE MEDINA WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CREATE GOMEZ CO FOUNDER THIS IS
TO WEAR IS FREEDOM COALITION AS
WELL AS THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. NATIONAL DOG PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR YOUNG WAS FREEDOM
CENTER IN SUPPORT. ALEXA YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER IN IN
SUPPORT. IMANI YOUR WOMEN'S
FURNACE. I TELL ME A YOUNG
WOMAN'S FREEDOM. FREEDOM SEVEN
IN SUPPORT. STEPHANIE MANDINGO
AND WOMEN FOR THIS AREA SUPPORT.
BANCO BROWN YOUNG WOMEN TO
FREEDOM CENTER AND WAS. IT'S
NOT CERTAIN AND IS ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
LENDING CROWDY LEGAL SERVICES
REPRESENTS WHAT CHILDREN IS
STRONG SUPPORT. RIGHT ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LET'S SEE
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT. ONE NINE- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS- I THINK IT'S A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND CALIFORNIANS
NEED TO DISCUSS AN ODD IN
ADDITION TO THE VARIOUS-
REASONS THAT ALL ALL OF YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE AUTHOR
DESCRIBE FOR WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT. TO THE CHILDREN OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
SHOULD NOT BE THE VICTIMS TODAY
AND THOSE CHILDREN AS WE KNOW
IN MANY MANY CIRCUMSTANCES END
UP IN FOSTER CARE. AND IF NOT
FOUGHT HERE THEN IS DESCRIBED
IT IS WITHOUT THAT PERSON DOUBT
PARENT BEING ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR SUPPORT. THEY ARE
THERE'S A VERY SERIOUS CYCLE OF
POVERTY. AND THEIR PARENT WHILE
INCARCERATED IF THEY'RE WORKING
BEING ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
TOWARDS THAT CHILD SUPPORT. AND
WELFARE ALSO REDUCES THE COST
TO THE STATE BECAUSE MUCH OF
THE I MEAN THE POVERTY PROGRAMS
ARE FUNDED BY TAXPAYERS AND YOU
HAVE A PERSON THAT. WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED THEY'RE
WORKING COULD BE OFF CITY THAT-
TAXPAYER BURDEN IN ADDITION TO
GREATLY IMPROVING THE CONDITION
OF THOSE CHILDREN- SO I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF. THIS OF YOUR
INITIATING THIS DISCUSSION AND
THIS RESOLUTION AND WOULD ASK
TO BE A CO AUTHOR YOUR WILL.
MORE THAN WILLING THANK YOU
MANAGER SO THE RESOLUTION ALL
RIGHT AND CENTER MITCHELL DID
YOU WANNA MAKING FUN. WISH IT
WAS A BILL THAT A RESOLUTION
BUT I WOULD RATHER. ALL RIGHT
SENATOR JACKSON'S. COME ON IN
AND- YOU STARTED TO PLACE
ORDERS A LOT OF DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THIS RESOLUTION DEALS
WITH- THE INABILITY TO HELP
SUPPORT ONE'S FAMILY WHILE
INCARCERATED HE INABILITY TO.
PAY CHILD SUPPORT THIS WAS AN
ISSUE THAT I SO MANY YEARS AGO
WORD WHEN MAN PARTICULAR ONE
COURSE RATED AND. THE LOOK YOU
KNOW NO OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
PARTNERS AND THEIR CHILDREN TO
COME TO GET ANY ANY
COMPENSATION WHICH OF COURSE
MEANT THAT THE PUBLIC WAS
PAYING FOR THROUGH THE WELFARE
SYSTEM. IS THERE SOMETHING IN
THIS RESOLUTION I DIDN'T SEE IT
BUT IS THERE SOMETHING THAT
TALKS ABOUT. IN PAYING A
REASONABLE. RATE FOR PEOPLE'S
WORK WHICH I THINK IS JUST
FUNDAMENTAL IS THERE SOME. A
MECHANISM TO ASSURE THAT IF
THERE ARE A DEBT TO
RESPONSIBILITIES OR CHILDREN
THAT SOME OF THAT. INCOME WILL.
GO FOR THAT PURPOSE SO THAT
THAT THE ART THAT THE CHILDREN
OF THESE INCARCERATED FOLKS
WE'LL BE SEEING SOME MONEY- AS
A RESULT OF THE LABOR THEIR
PARENTS AND IN PRISON. RECORD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
FOR YOUR DILIGENCE ON THIS
ISSUE- THE CURRENT LAW ACTUALLY
A REQUIRES A CHILD SUPPORT
ORDER TO CONTINUE WHILE THE
UNLESS A PERSON CAN SHOW
POVERTY UP UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
TEN A CALIFORNIA AND MANY OTHER
STATES WERE NOT ALLOWING A
PERSON WHO WAS IN PRISON I TO
DECLARE INVOLUNTARY POVERTY
THEY WERE AS STATING THAT THIS
WAS VOLUNTARY PRETTY AND
THEREFORE THE ORDERS WILL
CONTINUE BEING AS A RESULT THE
AVERAGE PERSON A PERSON EXITING
PRISON HAS AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CHILD SUPPORT AT THE DANGER.
THE CHANCE TO HAVE BEEN THE
CASE. AFTER AFTER THAT COURT
CASE THE MOMENT CAN ISSUED A
NEW RULES IN TWENTY SIXTEEN-
CALIFORNIA WAS SUPPOSED TO
IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE TO CLAIM
INVOLUNTARY POVERTY DURING
IMPRISONMENT AND TO REDUCE THIS
ORDER BUT THAT THAT IS BASED ON
THEIR CONDITION OF NOT BEING
PAID IF THEY WERE INDEED OR
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR THEY
WOULD HAVE TO PAY THE SAME OR
FIFTEEN OR THIRTEEN WHICH IS
THE MINIMUM WAGE TODAY THANK
YOU TO THE SENATE A FOR LEADING
THAT CHARGE. AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO PAY A THE SAME THING
WITH SOME ELSE WOULD HAVE TO
PAY AT THIRTEEN DOLLARS THERE
WILL BE SOME INSISTS THAT MONEY
WOULD BE GOING OUT AND
SUPPORTING THE FAMILY. OKAY ART
I CALL IT HAS AN AMPLE. RIGHT
EARLY IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
CDC IMPLEMENTED A JOINT VENTURE
PROGRAM OF THE ALLOWED PRIVATE
THE WHOLE COMPANIES TO COME TO
THE PRISON ACTUALLY WORK AND
SET UP SHOP TO REDUCE THINGS
LIKE SUNGLASSES AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THE CDC DID IS THEY SET
UP BANK ACCOUNTS FOR EACH
PRISONER THAT PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM. AND 50% OF THE
MONEY THAT A PERSON WOULD GET
FROM PAYCHECK WOULD GO TOWARDS
RESTITUTION AND GO TOWARD OTHER
FINDS AN OBLIGATION THAT THEY
HAD INCLUDING CHILD SUPPORT AND
THEN THEY TOOK THE OTHER 50%
ACTUALLY PUT IN A BANK ACCOUNT
FORM. I THINK MAKE ABOUT. THE
TIME THAT THEY WERE USING. I'LL
BE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY. UPON
RELEASE SO YOU WOULD JUST GET
THAT MONEY I TRUST ACCOUNT PER
SE YOU WOULD HAVE THE MONEY. IN
A BANK ACCOUNT BUT- X. AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS WOULD GO TO YOUR
TRUST ACCOUNT FOR THINGS LIKE
CANTEEN ETCETERA. THEN YOU ALSO
HAVE A SAVINGS. THAT TO THE
SIDE FOR YOU SO. AFTER A YEAR
TWO YEARS THREE YEARS FOUR
YEARS FIVE YEARS WORKING. YOU
OUT OF A VIABLE SUM OF MONEY.
THAT YOU COULD USE TO EITHER
SEND HOME TO YOUR FAMILY SAID
YOUR WIVES AND YOUR PARENTS AND
YOUR SISTER OR TO USE. ON RE
ENTRY. WHICH I THINK IS
VALUABLE BECAUSE WHEN YOU CAN
PAROLE. OR BE THESE FROM
PRESENT WITH MONEY TO SUSTAIN
YOUR HOUSING WITH MONEY TO
SUSTAIN YOUR TRANSPORTATION.
AND NOT HAVE TO RELY ON THE
STATE AND GO TO SOCIAL SERVICES
AND GO TO THAT WHOLE- MORASS.
OF STUFF THAT WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH WE GET OUT. AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT SYSTEM I
THINK IT'S JUST. INVALUABLE I
THINK. SO THAT'S MY- MY- WHEN
CAN. BUT I DO WANNA. SAY N. TO
FOLLOW UP WITH WHAT THE CHURCH
SAID- HERE THIS DOES CREATE A
CYCLE OF POVERTY IF WE TO AND-
THE NOTION. AND I HOPE WE GET
WAY FOR THIS NOTION THAT WE-
PEOPLE EVEN AFTER THEY'VE DONE
THEIR TIME. OF THE NOTION THAT
YOU GET OUT WITH TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND AFTER YOU PAY THE
FIVE DOLLARS EVERY TIME YOU DO
A TRANSACTION OR THE MONEY THAT
IT COSTS YOU TO MAKE PHONE
CALLS. WE GOTTA START TREATING
PEOPLE IN PRISON LIKE HUMAN
BEINGS BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING
TO GET OUT AND IF WE WANT TO
KEEP THEM OUT AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND I THINK MANY OF
US HERE BEEN TO- HAVE SEEN THIS
IN THE HALL I KEEP THINKING
BACK ON THE TRIP I TOOK TO THE
HOLDEN PRISON. IN NORWAY NO
PEOPLE COME IN AND THEY TREAT
THEM LIKE HUMAN BEINGS AND THEY
AG AND WHEN YOU'RE TREATED LIKE
A HUMAN BEING AND PROBABLY
KNOWS FOR ANYONE THERE ARE
CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS THAT YOU
ARE GOING MEET BUT IF YOU
TREATED. AS LESS THAN A PERSON
YOU BEHAVE THAT ASIAN THAT
WHEN YOU TREAT PEOPLE BADLY.
YOU DON'T REYES SAID BAR YOU'RE
GONNA SEE PEOPLE AT THAT LOWER
LEVEL. OF BEHAVIOR AND THAT.
DOESN'T BENEFIT ANYBODY SO THE
NOTION. THAT WE PAY PEOPLE WHAT
IS IT THREE CENTS TO THIRTY
CENTS TO THREE DOLLARS I MEAN
WHAT WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THE
WHAT WE THINK OF THE VALUE OF
SOMEBODY'S WERE. AND SO ARE
YEAH I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE YOU
KNOW WHAT THE ULTIMATE DOLLARS
ARE BUT I THINK IS A BASIC
PRINCIPLE WE'VE GOT TO START
RECOGNIZING AS THEY DO IN
NORWAY THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET OUT OF PRISON. THEIR
AVERAGE LENGTH OF TIME FOR A
MAJOR OFFENDERS EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TO THREE YEARS. SO THEY START
RIGHT WHEN THOSE PEOPLE GO INTO
PRISON THE HELP THEM FIGURE OUT
HOW NOT TO COME BACK. ONE OF
THE WAYS TO TREAT PEOPLE LIKE
HUMAN BEINGS. IT'S WHITE THAT'S
A DIRECTION WHICH WERE MOVING.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
HER COMMENTS AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR. BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION I
HOPE THAT THAT'S THE
CONVERSATION WE START HAVING
RATHER THAN. CONTINUING TO
PUNISH PEOPLE THEY'VE DONE
THEIR TIME- HOPEFULLY DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME THEY'VE
LEARNED A TRADER THEY'VE
LEARNED. WHATEVER IT IS A
CAUGHT THEM THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND HOW TO OVERCOME THAT.
SO THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE COST
OF THESE PRISONS IS JUST
RIDICLOUS. COMPARED TO WHAT WE
PAY TO EDUCATE CHILDREN AND
KEEP THEM OUT OF PRISON SO. I
HOPE WE'RE IN A POSITIVE
TRAJECTORY AND I THINK THIS IS
A RESOLUTION THAT WILL
CERTAINLY HELP US GET THERE SO
THANK YOU. FOR THAT THANKS FOR
THE AFTERNOON SAY A FEW WORDS.
FOR MORE LIKE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS A VERY INTRIGUING
IDEA BUT LOOKING AT THE DATA IN
THE IN THE HISTORY AND ALSO OUR
STAFF REPORT- OR- CALIFORNIA
MAY BE BELOW THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE BUT IT'S NOT VERY FAR
BELOW WORK. SO THIS IS THIS IS
THE. THE WAY THINGS ARE BEING
DONE ALL FIFTY STATES SO I'M
I'M I'M KIND OF CURIOUS. ABOUT
TWO THINGS ONE IS WE'RE NOT AN
OUT LIAR. WE'LL BE DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT WHAT WOULD
THE INDUSTRY IN FORTY NINE
STATES BE THINKING AND THE
SECOND WOULD BE WHERE WOULD THE
FUNDING COME FROM. AS WE
ALREADY HAVE A PRETTY. FREE.
LARGE BUDGET FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND IN REGARDS TO OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WITH A
GROUP GREAT PRIDE IN LEADING
THE NATION IN ALMOST EVERYTHING
ELSE SO WHY SHOULD WE LEGALIZE
NATION AND PRISON REFORM IN
RESTITUTION TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WORK ON AGAIN WE ENDED SLAVERY
IN THIS COUNTRY AND- EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE AND JUST BECAUSE ONE
HAS COMMITTED A CRIME DOESN'T
MEAN THAT. YOU SHOULD BE
ENSLAVED AND NOW FORCED TO WORK
FOR FREE SO WHY SHOULDN'T
CALIFORNIA LEAD AWAY AND
SHOWING HOW WE CAN TREAT
INDIVIDUALS WERE INCARCERATED I
THINK ON SENATOR FROM SANTA
BARBARA CLEARLY- GAVE EXAMPLES
OF HOW THE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
TREAT THEIR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS SO WHY SHOULD WE
WANT TO FOLLOW THAT MODEL. AS
FAR AS THE BUDGET IT'S ALL
ABOUT PRIORITIES THIS IS A
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRIES A
PRISON LABOR AND JUST FROM.
LICENSE PLATES AND ALL THE
OTHER STUFF THAT WE BUY IN THIS
BUILDING ALONE WE COULD AFFORD
TO PAY ARE IN MAKES FAR MORE
THAN EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AFTER SO. BEFORE
I ASK FOR THE CLOTHES. I WANTED
TO JUST MAKE THE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT THAT. WELL I FOCUSED ON
CHILDREN I THINK- SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU'RE VERY POINT THAT
THIS THAT HOW THIS SYSTEM WAS
EVEN ABLE TO EVOLVE WAS THROUGH
THAT- AMENDMENT TO OUR
CONSTITUTION. THAT WHILE IT
ELIMINATED SLAVERY ALLOWED FOR
SLAVERY WITHIN THOSE PEOPLE
WHOM WE INCARCERATE AND WE ARE
STILL. THIS IS A THIS IS STILL
A REMNANT OF THAT AND I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE WHAT WE AS A STATE
AND I THINK THE SOCIETY AT
LARGE BUT DEFINITELY WE AS A
STATE. HAVE BEEN MOVING
CLEARING CLEAR ROAD IS THAT IT
IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
RELY ON ANY ONE'S LABOR.
WITHOUT COMPENSATION FOR THAT
LABOR AND WE MADE A FIRST STEP
THIS LAST YEAR WITH STUDENT
ATHLETES WHILE WE DO NOT
GUARANTEE THEM PAY. WE AT LEAST
RECOGNIZED THAT THEY WERE
PRODUCING WEALTH THAT THEY WERE
NOT BEING ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
AND IN THIS CASE. ARE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS ARE
PRODUCING WEALTH AND THEY'RE
PRODUCING GOODS FOR THE HOOD
THE STATE AND MANY OTHERS. AND
THE IRONY IS AND THEN IT'S A
GREAT COST TO THE STATE FOR
SETTING IT UP THAT WAY BECAUSE
EITHER. THE PERSON OF EITHER
THEIR RESTITUTION IS NOT BEING
PAID THEIR CHILDREN ARE NOT
BEING SUPPORTED OR THEY
THEMSELVES COME OUT WITH HUGE
DEBT BECAUSE YOU WHATEVER DATE
YOU HAD WHEN YOU WALK IN A
PRISON YOU STILL HAVE WHEN YOU
COME OUT. AND WE JUST
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR INABILITY
TO REALLY BE SUCCESSFUL- SO
IT'S SIX HUGE IS FILE COST WEST
WE HAVE DESIGNED A STRUCTURE
THAT COSTS US IN ADDITION TO
NOT PROVIDING ANY DIGNITY THE
PERSON AND VIOLATING THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE THAT.
PERSON WHO IS PRODUCING IS.
PARTICIPATING LABOR SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED FOR THAT LABOR SO
I- I WELCOME THIS CONVERSATION
AND AS I SAID I'M VERY VERY.
PLEASED IF YOU'RE WILLING TO BE
A STRONG COLLECTOR YES. YES
SENATOR MOORLACH. JUSTIN
ACCOUNTING QUESTION. HE USED TO
BE A TREASURER OF A SUMMER CAMP
SO WE LOOK AT THE WHOLE.
PACKAGE PAPER WORK BUT YOU ALSO
HAD HOUSING AND MEALS. AND I'M
JUST WONDERING HOW HOW DOES
HOUSING AND MEALS FIT INTO THE
EQUATION AND WITH THAT BE PART
OF THE FACTOR OF WHY. THE
HOURLY RATES ARE SO LOW IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE HISTORY OF IT.
BUT A THING SENATOR BERNIE AND
MAY MENTION THE HISTORY.
EARLIER WHICH IT GOES ALL THE
WAY BACK TO THE- MATH MASON
POCKET WE'RE SITTING IN THE
REPORT THAT THAT EVEN THE WAGES
HAVE GONE DOWN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE SO I'M I'M. BY THE
WAY TO THE BOND ALLEN IS WILL
WITHIN THE PRISON SYSTEM
BECAUSE MOST OF THE SERVICES
THAT HAVE GONE DOWN FOR
PRISONERS IN CALIFORNIA PRISON.
IN IN THE IN CDC HAVE GONE DOWN
AS WELL A MAJORITY OF THE
BUDGET WHICH IS QUITE LARGE AS
YOU ALL KNOW. GOES TO STAFF AND
SERVICES IN THE UNION XIN IS AN
OLDER ENGINES IN THE UNION HAS
BECOME VERY STRONG THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS. AND THEY'VE
CREATED AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
WEALTH OFF THE BACK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED FROM THAT
IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE INSIDE
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO PRISON.
EVERYBODY HAD SOME TYPE OF PAIN
NUMBER WERE YOU WOULD
COMPENSATE EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT
THAT YOU. THE THAT THEY HAVE
NOW NOW VIRTUALLY NOBODY GETS
COMPENSATED THIS IS LIKE A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE IN
PRISON AND ACTUALLY GET PAID
EVEN AT THE TEN CENTER TWENTY
CENTS. AN HOUR- TYPE OF LABOR
WAITED SO THE SERVICE IN COPLEY
GONE DOWN FOR US IN REFERENCE
TO REHABILITATION SERVICES JOBS
PAY X. THAT ARE. OUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE THE STAFF- MY GONE
UP SO THERE'S A BIG IMBALANCE
BETWEEN ACTUALLY WHAT IS BEING
DELIVERED TO US AND FORMER
SERVICES. FIRST ACTING TO- THE
ADMINISTRATION SEES ITSELF- BUT
THE HISTORY I MEAN THAT'S
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF START WITH
THE BILL COLIN TO BE ABLE TO-
FIND A PERSON CONVICTED OF A
CRIME THEN LEASING THEM OUT
FOR. A SLAVE LABOR SO TO SPEAK
IN SMALL WAGES- AND IT'S
CONTINUE ON. TO THE ENACTMENT
THIRTEEN THE MEMBER OF PEOPLE
TO. ACTUALLY PUT IS INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE. BECAUSE WE'VE
COMMITTED A CRIME AND WE THINK
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY. THE
VISIT SOMETIME SOON- AND NOW
THE COLORADO LEAD. IN
INNOVATION IN THIS AREA MORE
THAN CALIFORNIA. CENTER THANK
YOU FOR GROWTH YOU KNOW THANKS
FOR LETTING ME JUST TESTS AND
QUIZZES AS A COMEDIAN
APPRECIATED RIGHT AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ASK WHEN YOU DO
SO FINE I OTHERWISE I WAS GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR MITCHELL
RESULTING FOR OKAY GREAT CENTER
MITCHELL. I WAS JUST GONNA
REPLY ALSO TO OUR COLLEAGUES
QUESTION I AND I GET THE LOGIC
OF THE CORRELATIONS THAT WE
CHARGE PEOPLE FOR SOME OF THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
INCARCERATING THEM AND THAT
WASN'T THE DESIGN. IN IT. GOES
BACK TO THE CHAIN GANGS THAT
THERE IS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND
AND I AM OPEN TO BE CORRECTED
THERE IS NO CORRELATION WE
DON'T DRAW DOWN ANY OF THEIR
SALARY RE DIRECTED TO- COVERING
THEIR EXPENSES LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
FOR JUVENILES WHERE WE ACTUALLY
CHARGE FEES ARE USED TO BEFORE
BILL PASSED ON TO THEM TO COVER
THEIR INCARCERATION THE PAYMENT
IS NOT A CORRELATION AT ALL- IT
IT AND SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THE COST THAT WOULD BE BORN IN
INCREASING THE PAYMENT WOULD
COME OUT OF THE PROFIT EARNED
BY DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
FOR FAILING FURNITURE TO THE
STATE OF THE GRAVITY THE LENSES
FOR MEDI CAL FOR GLASSES. THERE
IS A PROFIT EARNED OFF OF- THAT
THAT LABOR AND THERE HAS NEVER
BEEN A CORRELATION BETWEEN
INMATE EARNINGS PAIN AGAINST
THEIR EXPENSES FOR BEING
INCARCERATED THAT WAS NEVER THE
DESIGN I THINK THAT FOR ME THAT
THAT'S THE RUB THAT IT'S NOT AS
IF THEY ARE PAYING FOR THEIR
BOARD A IT KEEP IF YOU WILL. IT
IS A PROFIT POINT. AND THEREIN
LIES THE INAPPROPRIATENESS FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. CENTER BRADFORD UNIT
CLOSE I THINK WE CAN GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSER I THINK-
DISCUSSIONS BEEN A GREAT CLOSER
AND I WAS ASKED EARLIER WHY IS
THIS RESOLUTION AND I WAS
HESITANT TO A RESOLUTION I
WOULD HAVE PREFERRED A BILL BUT
WE UNDERSTAND JUST ON SOME
DISCUSSION WE HEARD I THINK
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP AND I
THINK THE DIALOGUE IN THE
DISCUSSION ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE. IS OR WHY THIS
RESOLUTION IS HERE TODAY AND I
THINK IT'S NEEDED BUT IF WE AS
LEGISLATORS ONLY LEGISLATE FROM
WHAT WE SEE IN FRONT OF US
RIGHT NOW AND NOT GO BACK TO
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE HOW WE
GOT HERE WE'RE GONNA MISS THE
POINT AND HOW WE GOT HERE IS
BECAUSE OF SLAVERY. AND ABOVE-
ABOLISHMENT OF SLAVERY AND THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT BUT WE
DON'T KNOW THAT HISTORICAL
CONTENT WE CAN SAY WELL WHY
SHOULD WE PAY ON THAT ALL AGAIN
NO ONE SHOULD BE FORCED TO WORK
FOR FREE AND THE INDIVIDUALS
WERE IN PRISON CHOOSE TO WORK.
BECAUSE THEY COULD STAY IN
THEIR CELL EVERY DAY INTO I'M
NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING BUT THE
CHOOSE THE WORK BUT THEY SHOULD
BE PAID FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. AND. IN THE DOLLARS BUT THE
SAME TIME THEY'VE SHOULDN'T GET
RICH OFF OF IT EITHER BUT AT
THE SAME TIME YOU SHOULD.
PROVIDING INDIVIDUAL WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ONE LIVE IN
DIGNITY. AND HAS WASH MONSTER
SAYS LEAVE A INSTITUTION WITH
SOME SENSE OF. MONEY IN YOUR
POCKET BECAUSE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN A BUS VEERED DOESN'T
GET YOU ANYTHING AND HAVE SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO RESTART A LIFE
AND WE JUST HEARD JUST PART OF
THIS ABOUT THE RECIDIVISM AND
THE WALLS IN THE FEARS OF
INCREASED CRIME HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL KEEP RELEASING
FOLKS WITH NO MONEY IN THEIR
POCKET WHAT ELSE THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO WHAT GOT THEM IN PRISON. AND
THIS IS HOPING WITH WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT ADDRESSING ALL THAT
SYSTEMIC CAUSES OF CRIME THIS
IS OE OF THE WAYS THAT WE HELP
IN RECIDIVISM SO IT'S A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OKAY. SKINNER
USUAL MOTION BUT- I CAN I
MOORLACH WITH THE WITH WHATEVER
CO AUTHORS MISTER BRADFORD ONCE
ADD MORE LYE FINE. BRADFORD OUR
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL I'M
AROUND. WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER
AYE. RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND CENTER
BRADFORD YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL
JEFFERSON THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AS J. R. TEN WHICH CALL
FOR CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO ENACT
LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD REMOVE
CANNABIS FROM THE FEDERAL DRUG
SCHEDULE UNDER CURRENT LAW
CANNABIS REMAINS WILL SET A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG ALONG WITH
OTHER DRUGS SUCH AS HEROIN AND
LSD. THIS CURRENT SYSTEM IS
SERIOUSLY FLAWED OTDATED IT
HAS IMPOSED SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS INDUSTRY CANADA'S HAS
LIMITED HAS UNLIMITED POTENTIAL
FOR ABUSE ESTABLISHED MEDICAL
USES AND IS SAFE RELATIVE TO
OTHER SUBSTANCES LISTED ON THE
FOR PRO DRUG SCHEDULED SIMPLY
MOVING CANNABIS TO A LESS
RESTRICTIVE SCHEDULE WOULD NOT
PROTECT EXISTING MEDICAL
CANNABIS PROGRAMS NOR WILL
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM BEING
ARRESTED AND PUNISHED FOR USING
CANNABIS FOR RECREATION
PURPOSES REMOVING CALPERS FROM
THE DRUG SCHEDULE WOULD ALLOW.
SURGED FACILITIES TO DO REGULAR
RESEARCH INTO THE FAX CANNABIS
AND HELP YOUR AND APPROVAL AND
SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY FOR OUR
STATE THIS RESOLUTION IS
IMPROPER IS A PRO I PROGRESS
STEP TOWARD. A MORE JUST STRUCK
POLICY IN OUR CLASS REGARD THE.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT GOOD MORNING GOING
BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING UNLAWFULLY SOME HAVE
REUNITED KIND OF THIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MIKE A
DOCTOR OF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS PART. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES BY TO HAVE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. MOVE THE
RESOLUTION RIGHT SO WE HAVE THE
RESOLUTION BEFORE US WE HAVE
DISCUSSION. FOR YOU CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
IS AGAIN ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
WHERE. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BEING BEHIND AND NOT IN STEP
WITH STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IS CREATING A VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR US TO
LEGALIZED IN A WAY THAT REALLY
PROTECTS PEOPLE SAFETY. AND IT
ACHIEVES THE TYPE OF GOALS THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN THE
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT FOR
US BEFORE US IN IF YOU WANT TO
CLOSE. YES I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE AND JUST LIKE THE MEASURE
PREVIOUS MEASURE ALL WE'RE HERE.
BECAUSE OF A RACIST POLICY IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES. THE ONLY
REASON CANNABIS WAS EVER MOVE
TO A SCHEDULE ONE WAS TO REST
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
BUT WE DON'T KNOW THE
HISTORICAL ASPECTS OF THAT.
CANNABIS HAVE BEEN USED FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS. HELP. YOU
NAME IT BUT NOT UNTIL THE EARLY
LATE NINETEEN TWENTIES. WAS
THERE THE MOVE TO HOW DO WE
INCARCERATE BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE HOW DO WE CARTER GREAT
CARS READ AGAIN PEOPLE WHO WORK
NOW FREE PEOPLE WERE NOW
MIGRATING TO THIS COUNTRY AND
THAT'S THE HISTORY BUT AGAIN WE
CONSTANT LEGISLATE FROM WHERE
WE ARE TODAY AND NOT LOOK AT
HISTORICAL ASPECTS AGAIN.
CANNABIS IS A PLANT I DRUG IS
SOMETHING MAN MADE WE DID NOT
CREATE THIS PLANT WE INVITE OF
ENHANCE IT TO HORTICULTURE AND
IN SCIENCE BUT. WHAT WE EVER
DISCOVERED IT IT WOULD STILL BE
ON THIS PLAN. SO A DRUGS HEROIN
A DRUGS COCAINE A DRUG IT'S ALL
THOSE THINGS NOW THAT PEOPLE
WANNA SAVE SOCIETY FROM AND
HAVE REHABILITATION AND
CANNABIS IS BEEN AROUND SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF TIME. AND IT'S
A COMMONSENSE TIME THAT WE MOVE
INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY A
BULLET FROM A SCHEDULE ONE
ALLOWED TO BE WHAT IT IS A PLAN
SORRY SELECT LAST YEAR I VOTE.
RIGHT ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WE HAVE A MOTION. LET'S TAKE
RECALL WHAT'S THE MOTIONS
PACIFIC WE BE ADOPTED ALL RIGHT
TO ROLL CALL. SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH AYE
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MORALE. AROUND A
WIENER WIENER AYE. I WILL HOLD
IT OPEN- SO WE CAN DO WILL DO A
ROLL CALL IN ALL THE MOTIONS
WERE HOLDING ONE THREE OF OUR
MEMBERS BACK AND- UNDER MORE
LIKE A MOVIE. EXCELLENT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LET'S TO ROLL CALL
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE
MOORLACH FOR LIKE AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MORALE HIGH MORALE
AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE.
EXCELLENT SO WILL. THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS VOTE ONLY
SKINNER NO SKINNER NOW MORE
LOCK WELL LIKE I BRADFORD LOOK
RIGHT FOR NOW JACKSON. NOT
VOTING MITCHELL ROW BY ROW AYE
WIENER WIENER NOW. ALL RIGHT
THAT MOTION. IT WILL ALSO HOLD
TO ADD ON- ARE THERE ANY BILLS
THAT WE NEED TO REOPEN THEIR
OFFER ANY OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE PRESENT. LET'S OPEN REOPEN
THE ROLE FOR SB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER ONE. THE VOTE
IS- FIVE ZERO RIGHT NOW GO
AHEAD JACKSON JACKSON HIGH
WIENER WIENER HIGH. ALL RIGHT
THAT BILLS OUT. THREE SEVEN TO
ZERO AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WANTS TO OPEN ANY OTHER MEMBER
HERE'S. AHEAD. CHECK PLEASE. IS
IT ONLY SENATOR MITCHELL WHO
STILL IS OUT ON. YEAH THERE.
OKAY ONLY SENATOR MITCHELL I
STAND ON SO WE WILL HOLD IT FOR
SENATOR MITCHELL TO RETURN. IF
ENACTED
. THE GROWTH. ALL RIGHT
LET'S RE OPEN THE ROLE IN A
COUPLE OF BILLS WILL START WITH
FIRST THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO
YOU PASS THE FLOOR CONSECUTIVE
CONSENT CAPTION WHICH A LOT OF
TALK OR IF THE LET'S GO TO- SB
SEVEN TEN SENATOR BATES FILL
THE VOTE RIGHT NOW IS. FOUR
NINE FOUR TWO FIVE FOUR NO. GO
AHEAD MICHELLE. MICHELLE NOW.
OKAY THE BILL FAILS LET'S GO TO.
S. G. R. TEN SENATOR BRADFORD.
VOTE RIGHT NOW IS- FIVE ONE
SIX. METAL ON METAL **** NUMBER
SIX WHAT IT WAS BEFORE OKAY SO
AND THEN WE GO TO THE VOTE ONLY
CORRECT YEAH ALL RIGHT TO VOTE
ONLY WAS SB ONE SIX ONE ITEM
SEVEN AND THAT- VOTE SO FAR IS.
TO I THREE NO ONE NOT VOTING
MITCHELL MITCHELL NOW. RIGHT
THAT THEY'LL AND SALES AND THAT
IF WE GET EVERYBODY GET
EVERYTHING. YEAH OKAY EXCELLENT
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. IS A
JERK